man whoo we had a good time with at the
the big slick tournament this past
summer in Kansas City mr. Oklahoma and
Dallas Cowboy himself the host of the
bachelor which debuted with a three-hour
special on Monday night season 23 of The
Bachelor with Chris Harrison a short
three hour premiere I know it flew by it
was like that it was just well you know
we do three hours every day right Chris
you know but I don't think you guys it
was easy for us it was it was some tough
sledding I know I know if we upset some
fans it was like we didn't need all that
of course you didn't need all that I
mean you don't need to have that extra
piece of cake he was a gift
welcome people are complaining was a
little long we stretched it out a little
bit it's the three hours I mean it was
an extravagance it was actually really
fun because we had so many for Merle you
know kind of alumni come back and write
and family members and we were you know
simulcast across the country and doing
live TV with people that have never done
live TV before as you know you a lot
with these people and always makes it
interesting but it was fun I enjoyed the
show and it did really well Colton
Underwood who was on he we had him on
game day morning on Saturday what a
sweetheart of an end of it he's a good
guy really good man a big man huge yeah
and I made the mistake of I when we're
on the road you know we're in Thailand
and Singapore in all these places
Colton loves to work out he's an you
know former NFL football player and not
that far removed and that's kind of his
thing every morning as you know these
guys really want to work out I said well
I'll work out with you right so I worked
out with him for a couple weeks and
how'd that work not well no lie right
now my hamstring is still a wreck no kid
just we did this one workout he's like
we did this workout with the Chargers
and it was like just some 30 minutes of
Sprint's up and down the beach the next
day I couldn't move but I had to act
like I could move because I didn't want
to be that guy that got my ass kicked by
you know this 26 year old yeah and I
used to you know when you when you get
older this is what you say well when I
was 26 he didn't matter what age I was I
never looked like that I could never run
like that yeah so and he's like I said
he was he couldn't have been he couldn't
be nicer
and yeah and yeah very beloved by our
crew really sweet guy I did a really
good job gave us a run for our money
literally and figuratively right
you saw the fence jumping incident yes
that happened and that was the other
tough part when you do it with an
athlete like that that can take a seven
and a half foot fence and make it look
like it was a hurdle I lost him for a
little bit right and then what was with
though one of the young ladies giving
him a dog to watch and then you wound up
apparently yeah that was the dog the
official dog I just sat out front with
my tea all night just walking this damn
dog right in the dog inside inside
baseball yes
the dog smelled really bad if you're
gonna bring a dog on the show bring ya a
little grooming right sure hygiene right
not gonna kill you exactly
I mean I'm as much of a dog guy as
anybody I think but I don't like stinky
dogs I'm correct and there was another
young lady who put on an accent when it
breathe what was that all she put on an
accident an accent what was it an
Austrian accent and by the way I'm not
an Aussie I'm from Texas I'm the
furthest thing from knowing about this
accent yes my opinion I thought it was
spot-on it was well I it was damn near
Crocodile Dundee right I thought he was
really really good and he fell for it
which is all that really matters she
nailed it but what does she think is
gonna happen cuz you you know keep this
thing up with her up the entire a
geminal a cello secret yes breaking news
yes men yes we're not smart animals a
beautiful blonde shows up with an accent
yeah over yeah done so that rose her
thought is he's gonna be smitten with
her and by the way he was it worked
until she came out with this kind of
Jersey accent and then it changed no
offense Jersey Watts Jersey over there
and Michael to faux Chris Harrison I
rest my case
on the Rich Eisen show so we we we were
chatting via text late December yes
prior to the National Championship
semi-final where you're look we're
getting ready to see calamari in
Oklahoma and Dallas was getting set for
Seattle right and I'm like okay when you
come on we're gonna talk about wins for
both you won for two right now well we
knew Oklahoma was not gonna probably
beat al
that was a foregone conclusion but then
again who would have thought that
Clemson was gonna put him in a body bag
exactly that was a pretty crazy to
switch but the Cowboys right here's what
worries me rich okay I actually feel
good about this weekend hit LA so they
got me this is the worst part I didn't
want to care I didn't want to believe
they beat Seattle at home that was a
great win a gutsy performance by dak
Prescott and now we're at LA which is
the best scenario why is that best I
mean put us in the dome in New Orleans
not a great place to be correct if we'd
had to go to Soldier Field or I mean so
many other places aren't great even if
we'd had to go to Seattle that would
have been a different ballgame playing
Seattle at home was huge for us but
going to LA a team that's not exactly on
fire
you know Girly's a little beat up golf
struggling a little bit he's lost his
favorite target it's almost too good to
be true
and then there's the fair-weathered
fandom of people like my two guys over
there who are season ticket although
they're all Rams good oh no I was a Rams
guy back in the day rich oh they don't
even they don't know they're both
transplants from the East Coast okay
and I love golf I mean here's my thing I
golf kind of lives up in my area and
I've gotten to know him he's a really
good guy and I wish him well yes um just
not sad but I just feel like set we're
seven-point dogs I don't see how we're
seven point dogs and LA I mean LA look
that those are your fans right over
there they've been fans for 14 minutes
now so it's not exactly like going to
Lambeau or going to Soldier Field and
seeing guys you want you want to defend
yourself yeah I paid for a PSL on the
new stadium already so did Brockman we
are faith
I've already seen where does the limo
drop you guys off at that stadium
actually sushi to go to Katsuya sushi
before the game by the way some stadiums
get the fan base up by playing charge
right
he's screaming I've been charged for my
PSL let's go Rams it's not really a
rallying cries I'm not exactly worried
about the hostile environment of Los
Angeles when everybody games at five
tene here you guys show up what it's
6:00 6:15 by I mean by half time anyway
the three dreaded words here in Los
Angeles
chance of rain yeah that is interesting
we're going to have weather which by the
way just don't get me started on weather
in Los Angeles but I don't know who that
really helps or hurts because la is not
used to it either Dallas I can't
remember we've had it really any
inclement weather this year that the
Cowboys are played and so I'm not sure
who that who's a better Mudder
well here's and you bring up an easy
point crack Chris Harrison here on the
Rich Eisen show is that the Rams are
obviously known for their scheme and
then they're wide open but Gurley can
hit you in the mouth that offensive line
can absolutely hit you in the mouth they
can be completely physical if they want
what Gurley do we have and this is well
you've got you've got yourself Zeke and
lettuce Gurley on the other side and two
terrific offensive lines two terrific
defensive lines this is really gonna be
a great NFC game higher in Los Angeles
because if I told you the Rams won going
away you'd believe it if I told you the
Cowboys won going away you could believe
that too when you go into a game and you
can really believe any scenario does
that means it's gonna be a great
football game I love that and they're
deep the Cowboys defense we made fun of
Michael Irvin way back in September it's
easy to do I know we made fun of Michael
Irvin I loved way way back in September
when he started talking about the hot
boys and we're like you talking about
the hot boys that's what the front seven
began calling themselves with a hashtag
and the Z at the end instead of the S
the hot boys and what they have done in
the front seven this year has been
earth-shattering I mean they've been -
they've been terrific like you best make
your first step as a running back
forward not to decide and you best as a
quarterback take your first step to the
side not back it has that really swing
with you I think when everyone saw how
how much they got to Drew Brees and the
Saints you're like oh these guys are
legit mm-hmm it's gonna be it's gonna be
a heck of a game a really good game it's
gonna be a lot are you going can I tell
you okay so I didn't want to bring this
up go for because I love him and I'm
excited about this
so Cowboys are coming to town yes of
course I would be there I'm leaving
tomorrow to go to Hawaii to officiate
ari and Lauren's wedding oh my god which
happens to be Saturday afternoon in Maui
so here's the thing born and raised in
Dallas Texas could not be more of a
Dallas Cowboy faithful fan coming here
and then I have a friend in and they're
coming to my home I've had no less than
15 people offer me tickets try to sell
me tickets give me tickets yeah
and I have to tell them all I'm going to
Hawaii
to host a wedding and officiate a
wedding it's not like I could even say
I'm sick I'm just not going yes I'm
officiating the wedding yes so I called
Ari this morning and just to take his
temperature you know just to say hey you
know throw it out there kind of like
joking hey Cowboys are coming to town
you know hate to pay to not show up and
he's like don't you tear so cuz Ari's
been messed with me through he's leaving
a buddy in the foxhole there I got to
finish this so my Cowboys will be here
in my back yard
I'll be officiating wedding the wedding
starts around 5:00 I ask you yeah so
wait a minute that's that's eight
o'clock here right it's 5:15 to is
kickoff here in LA right so that's
what's the difference in Maui three
hours isn't it I think so I think it's
right now is we only had technology I
think it's three hours
okay that's confirmed so two hours in a
bar what time is tip-off for the wedding
that would be I it's around five o'clock
in Maui so I think I'm okay she's
totally Henry on time for her to
officiate this well I'll either be three
sheets to the wind and celebrating have
my my face and chest painted or I'll be
bawling my eyes out it's only two hours
only two hours two hours in the yeah
it's currently 9:00 11:00 a.m. and oh
okay
so it's only two hours this is gonna be
tight it is gonna be tight
yeah I might be a little later my child
in third quarter come on now here so
what are you gonna do
I mean I'll have my phone I think you
got to give a rose to an AV specialist
in
so this the first wedding you've ever
officiated no I've done about ten I have
done several and of the bachelor family
I've done a few on national TV thanks
for watching those rich Jaden Turner
idea Carly and Evan but this is not hold
on a second this isn't Telus
right no it's just I'm doing this purely
as a friend of Ari
I'll be very honest with you having seen
you done do this stuff before doing that
the proper language yes I didn't think
you were properly ordained to do it I am
but you this is really funny too so I'm
ordained in the state of California ari
appropriately texted me a couple weeks
ago and said can you do a wedding in
Hawaii and so my lovely assistant Karen
I said we should probably check on this
no I was not ordained to do a wedding in
Hawaii which almost was my out
unfortunately my assistant is really
good at what she does I'm now ordained
in Hawaii so I so folks in Hawaii if you
need me to come I'm there's expedited
paperwork yeah let's just yeah we yeah I
was a whole new thing I had to be
reordain didn't do it in Hawaii yeah cuz
I was about to say the word when having
been in Hawaii as much as I loved to go
with that the word expedited doesn't
leap to mind when you go to Hawaii well
in all fairness and I knew there was a
second week of the playoffs but this is
a while ago and I thought I'm not
worried about the cowboy sooner you're
gonna break my heart you know I don't
think at the time I don't think we had
acquired Amari Cooper yet so our lives
hadn't changed amazing it really is
amazing how the team has been here I
said Jon Gruden the case of champagne
this year yeah he's changed the
complexion I got so I'm infl I am
mandated to ask you Chris Harrison yes
are you officiating any weddings the
following Sunday or two Sundays after
that or no this is again this no I'm
setting my Dallas I'm sorry this is on
me okay because I'm setting myself up
for failure
I would love to go to New Orleans I Love
New Orleans one of my favorite cities
and if the Cowboys are fortunate enough
to go I will be in New Orleans how about
the best-case scenario B at Felix's with
a dozen raw and a dozen chargrilled and
Happiness can I shout out the best-case
scenario is you're in the Metroplex
you're in the Jones Mahal what the
Eagles coming in that's an do you think
the Saints could lose to the to Philly
oh how can you think it Nick Foles with
what's going on with him and think any
end but possible it is an amazing story
and I and being a Dallas guy you know
what I think of Philly I won't even say
it cuz I don't I don't want to hear some
family show right exactly so you know my
love for the Eagles that you probably
know where that lies but yeah if to
think that we could host the Eagles in
the AFC Championship at Jerry world
would be unbelievable the NFL player
that's come up to you said they're the
biggest die-hard fan of The Bachelor is
who oh man oh well the biggest I think
literally the biggest would be Urlacher
we played in a tournament together we
were at the Diamond Resorts in Florida
last year and Urlacher was there playing
and he's he's a big bachelor fan in a
big one he is eight the thing with our
lacquer when you see him in person
there's two things that are very jarring
one is the hair right now okay and we
have told him Brockman and I have told
him that he's left us behind and it's an
outrage it's an outrage it's an absolute
outrage that he too deep that he would
go the other way from the Brotherhood
but he's fine he's gone and he's never
coming back that's number one and then
number two is how he just keeps going up
yeah getting bigger he keeps going Rob
he still takes the Flintstone vitamins
yeah and I have another great NFL story
that actually goes to one of your topics
today of most hated NFL or hated athlete
yes but my mind is not from one of my
teams it's from another team a guy that
ruined my childhood okay I was sitting
at the old Drew Brees golf tournament
down to San Diego and this guy sits next
to me and he said hey are you Chris
Harris from The Bachelor and I look over
and I said yeah how you doing he said
Dwight Clark I said you son of a you
know you ruined my childhood right hmm
the catch obviously was against the
Cowboys if you guys haven't seen that
footage before yes
I mean can you replay that enough if
poor Everson walls uh but anyway so I
said you son he's like can I he's like
cowboy fan I said yeah he's like can I
buy you a beer so that's the least you
can do so Dwight Clark and I actually
became friends the man who ruined my
childhood God rest his soul you know but
we became friends and kept in touch for
many years one of the sweetest people
yeah one of the best he was so hard to
hate him after that I know even though
he ruined my childhood so but Montana
you could hate those yeah Montana
overrated
The Bachelor p.m. Eastern Time with
Colton Underwood Chris Harrison you're
the man
I really appreciate every time I go I
feel like I talk to you for an hour if
you guys can come up with something I
know there's a lot of men out there
watching if you guys can come up with a
way that I can get out of this wedding
there's no one and still be considered a
good guy
there's no way I don't see any way out
re lion Dyke would absolutely be very
upset with you yeah
Liam Neeson couldn't get it find a way
out of this for me mm-hmm I don't know
what I do you're gonna do it these blank
faces I'm trying to think I pick a
basketball pop it Achilles like I think
you have to injure yourself yes we don't
that's that's you know it's still
something that I can industrial I need
an industrial accident like I need to be
hit by it especially if the Rams go up
21 nothing then you really feel kind of
silly right well that's the thing if the
Rams start blowing it out well then I'm
done I'm like I'm gonna be like oh good
I'm in Maui I don't care right I can act
like I don't care okay let me know how
it is I'll be at home on that cab or
I'll be at the game you could say that
the the newest bachelor stands in for
you can we put the the the shot up right
here or there we go there's no he had a
choice of he had a choice what would she
make her Warner EO j and m JD and the
constructor brother that's a that's a
fascinating photograph for right there
does it make is that the the conceit
with Colton coming on is that all for
analysts were holding the helmet right
of a wild-card team that they were
saying should win the Super eight and he
wanted the
who did Colton think could be a
wild-card little better chosen well he
chose the the Cowboys were not in the
mix they're right well because my wild
card Michael our tree you were division
winner which one of the which one of out
cards why I get it so he chose Irvin
with the Chargers because he said he
loved me now that he was first team
charges he said his first love he's
still they talk about heartbreak he
still talks I think that was one of his
big regrets as was leaving the Chargers
because they were so good to him and he
thought he had a better opportunity
elsewhere but he misses playing with the
Chargers I mean you could tell he could
miss talking football - it was fun to
have mom yeah dude he's a good good to
have him around it's a great season I
think people are really gonna fall in
love with this guy cuz he's a regular
guy so much look so much was made of the
virginity and all this other stuff and
we'll deal with that on the show but I
I'm excited for people to actually get
to know I'm like you guys did yes this
is a good guy he's you know he's a good
guy yeah as he what went off I said he
was no longer saving himself for NFL
Network can you say what hanging can you
say that in all aspects well have a
great time in Maui if you want you do
want text upset yes I want command you I
100 per second hundred percent I want
updates okay yeah you got to be texting
me while the games nicer than happy to
yeah I really will okay and you'll
accept them very good wait will you be
in either New Orleans or Dallas if
there's no I'm here cuz I have to be on
the air at the crack of dawn Sunday
morning so I'm not going to the game and
plus plus I can't get tickets because
they've already been sold the Cowboys
fans on the secondary ticket market by
those twos do not third I have been a
Los Angeles resident for 16 years and if
you did not hear chance at rank no shot
no shut get a quarter of the Train the
city will shut down okay tell me this
before we go yes
so because I'm a cowboy fan at my
Country Club at the golf course
I took kind of all comers ok with the 7
points oh I turn to our resident expert
I felt good I think you should feel good
about that yeah feel good all right a
lot of friends a lot of friends live
let me tell you there was the easiest
fishing expedition I've ever been on
Chris B Harrison on Twitter and that's
also your Instagram it is if I'm not
mistaken okay check out Chris Harrison
on The Bachelor every single Monday
night at 8:00 Eastern Time your phone
calls and the news update when we return
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience